foreign
let's go to Mary in Bakersfield
California what's up Mary
hi what are you doing I'm great what are
you doing
I'm in my car I'm at work but I took a
little time aside to talk to you that's
fantastic do you look like a like a
phone creeper like in the car are they
gonna walk by and be like what's Mary
doing I don't think so I don't see
anybody right now good we have a cover
okay good all right so what's up
um well when I emailed your your show I
was talking about
um
how um I'm racially mixed I was born to
a Mexican mother and a white father okay
um they couldn't take care of me on
their own so I was uh put up for
adoption at Birth
um the family that um
took me in as my foster parents they
they adopted me officially at age when I
was four
and they're both white uh both from Ohio
they don't speak Spanish at all and what
I've noticed is
since I look Mexican I've noticed that a
lot of uh Hispanic people expect me to
speak Spanish
or fit in with the culture somehow and I
don't
and um I've never felt comfortable in my
own skin about it like um where I work I
work on the east side of town
and it's uh I guess I'd say 90 Spanish
speaking and um
sometimes the reactions I get from
people who are not speaking Spanish is
like they think I'm a traitor or like a
like I um
like I'm going against my race and they
though obviously they don't know my
story sure and it's really honestly it's
hurtful I get really hurt by by the the
judgment and um and honestly I've I've
met my my mother's family I met them
about 22 years ago and I have a half
brother on that side
and um I I hear I hear people talk about
how Mexican families are so close
but this one isn't and they're they're
just they're backstabby and I assume
that way they they treated my mother I
never got to meet her she died before I
could meet her and I see the way they
treated her and my brother
and I can see why they weren't there
and it hurts yeah
foreign
racial and ethnic identity stuff okay
yeah but at the core here
I I see how old are you Mary
uh 47 47.
yeah I just see a beautiful young woman
lost at sea
and I see a beautiful young woman lost
at sea who doesn't like herself
and I want to ask you
forget the voices
the voices that are asking you why did
your mom and dad
uh put you up for adoption why did you
get raised by a white family in Ohio why
do people in your neighborhood
constantly tell you you're not enough
you're too much whatever
take those voices aside for a second
that's hard I know those voices are hard
why don't you like Mary
um
I don't I won't say it I don't like
myself I just don't
I don't like how people treat me it's
usually other Mexicans that treat me
this way like I'm not Mexican enough and
they they don't they know I know but but
the fact that that voice gets into your
soul so much
well that's the side that rejected me
the Mexican side they reject my Mexican
Mother's family did not
take me and if it wasn't for my grandma
here we go hold on hold on hold on let's
go race a lot let's don't racialize this
okay okay
your mom's family said they don't want
anything to do with you
and that hurts let's sit on that for a
second
because what I don't want to do is I
don't want to take a paintbrush and
paint the entire Mexican culture because
you said Mexican films are supposed to
be like X and mine is like why
then what you're doing is you're doing
the exact same thing that those people
in your community are doing to you
they're looking at you and saying well
you should be like this and that's not
fair to do let's just look at this
family
that is choosing actively
to not be in your life we can't run from
that let's sit in that for a minute
because it hurts so bad
and if we avoid that grief
with all this other stuff the other
stuff is real the ethnic identity and
the racism that's all real
but when we avoid that hurt by this this
this
oh man
it's heavy
and what about your bio's dad's family
um I found
and they believe it or not most of them
live in Arkansas
I don't know why is that funny
well because it's a it's a weird story I
I haven't found him but I
I did track down
uh relatives in Arkansas through the DNA
test okay why haven't you reached why
don't you reached out to him
I I can't find them they they don't know
where he is either I I won't get into
that but okay okay
um but anyway I mean they've been good
about it I mean it's in my my mother's
family hasn't been all bad but I've seen
the way they not only treated my mother
when she was alive I've seen the way
they treat each other and if it hadn't
been for my maternal grandparents my
brother my my brother that I mentioned
he probably would have been put in the
Foster system too
by the time I came along they were too
old to take on an infant and nobody else
stepped up that my mother came from a
large family she was number number nine
out of ten children and somebody could
have stepped up and taken me and they
just didn't and that that right there
Mary
that's where you go to park
I can hear that your voice changes you
got so much anger there
yeah
they should have
yeah and now 47 year old Mary is
choosing to cut her life short with high
blood pressure and increased heart rate
and not sleeping and goofed up
relationships because you won't put that
anger down they should have shown up and
they didn't
and the question you gotta ask yourself
is am I going to continue to carry that
around like a sack of bricks on my
shoulder or am I going to set that crap
down
I have a little girl
she's seven
I can't imagine taking a breath of my
life without her anymore
and I can't even identify with what you
experienced as a kid I can't I can't
wrap my head around it
do you have kids of your own no okay
here's why I think you need to spend
some time with do I like Mary
it's really common
for people who have experienced what
you've experienced
even though it sounds nuts
there's a five or six or seven year old
little girl wondering
what is so wrong with me
what did I do
and I want to tell you you did nothing
mm-hmm
your mom and dad your bio mom and dad
had stuff going on in their life that
had nothing to do with you and you got
you were a casualty of it
your extended family on both sides
had stuff going on in their life had
nothing to do with you you were casualty
of it I'm so sorry
I grew up I've spent my whole life
except for the last five years in Texas
and so I there was a I think it was in
the 80s maybe 70s or 80s there was a
swath of I grew up around Mexican and
Hispanic people that's my that's my
that's my life and
um
there was a whole movement to not speak
Spanish in the home
and I've got many friends who were a
little bit who are younger than you but
uh not by a lot who's are so just pissed
that their parents didn't teach them
Spanish to teach them part of culture
and it's become this cool adventure not
a you should you should be not like that
that kind of pressure solves no problems
right it just creates gas like like like
uh like indigestion gas
but an adventure to find out huh how far
does a string go
and you've been on Ancestry so you've
been you've been digging right yeah yeah
yeah for years yeah
so I think
once you can start digging not out of
desperation to find out where I come
from but in a spirit of adventure and a
spirit of
I want to explore this
now you got a whole there's a whole
different attitude towards it and then
maybe one maybe one day uh let me ask
you this is a hard question
are you embarrassed that you can't speak
Spanish
no I mean I've taken Spanish classes and
I'm not
uh
are you embarrassed that you can't speak
Spanish yes or no
yes why
well because it's like that's right
well I mean I would like
I would like with the Mexican side I
wish I the thing is growing up I didn't
have that parent to identify with I
didn't have like what other ethnically
mixed people have like oh my my mom's
family was this so I used to go to my
you know if I I could have said oh yeah
my mom's Mexican and I used to grow up
go in my Thea's house or on my white
side I went to my aunt's house I don't
have that I didn't have that growing up
so I don't
I don't I can't identify with it why do
you why are you so mad at Mary for that
Mary didn't do anything yes you are
I can hear it when you when you say I
thought I'm mad at myself
when you're embarrassed that you can't
speak Spanish there's a difference
between being embarrassed and wishing I
could
my kids know my sister is tiloka
I wish with all of my heart I was more
fluent in Spanish I could speak a lot
more than I actually can
I wish but I'm not mad at myself for it
my wife's taking it right now
she's incredible at it she just chose
one day I just this is just dumb to only
know a little bit of Spanish
and we do it for Hospitality purpose we
want to be able to speak to people in
our community that we hang out with that
are our friends that we love
and so it's a Hospitality thing for us
but it's not a matter of I should have
and I suck and they should have told you
see you see the anger and rage you got
on this
now imagine you're in algebra class
and there's somebody screaming in your
ear you should know this you're idiot
is that can you learn under that
condition
no no
well then how do I how
do you think I would be out of out of
line if I the next person who
uh treats me differently for not
speaking Spanish you think I should tell
them hey the reason why I don't speak
Spanish is because I wasn't raised in
the Mexican family you think that would
be too bold
I don't think it's too cold at all but
maybe no no What's it gonna solve
well I mean I think they should know I
sometimes I think they should know hey I
wasn't raised by a Mexican family I may
be Mexican ethnically but I wasn't
raised by a Mexican family and so will
that make you feel will that make you
feel better
I think so I think I think I don't think
I should keep it a secret I I should be
able to talk about it or if you just
said quietly I got adopted by a white
family
I'm getting to the point where I'm
starting to I think people should know
like you know I'm sorry it
I wasn't raising a Spanish-speaking home
I wouldn't apologize for it
yeah
and I also implore you with all my heart
you gotta stop letting all these other
voices speak into who you are and what
your value is
you don't know these people
they're just neighbors clowning on you
an exercise that I did once that was
awful that ended up being amazing
was I want you to take up this is and
I'm passing it along to you this is your
homework assignment I want you to take a
small box
it could be a shoe box or it can be
something Fancy from a store I want you
to take a small box empty it out and put
it on your kitchen table this is just
you
and I want you to take out some note
cards
five of them
and I want you to write on the note card
the name of a person you are giving
permission to speak into your life
what I mean by speak in they get to tell
you
you shouldn't have done that
you just violated your core values
you need to take down that post off
social media that's what people in my
box are often telling me
you hurt me
they get to tell you those things
and if they're not in the Box your life
practice becomes
not caring what other people say and let
me be real honest with you I've taken my
parents out of my that box
I love them I've got great parents they
don't get a vote on how I raise my kids
they don't get a vote on what I should
or shouldn't be doing or what job I
should should be take that's not they
don't get a vote on that my in-laws
don't I love my in-laws I won the
lottery with my in-laws they don't get a
vote
I've got five friends and my wife
maybe six friends and my wife those are
the people I've given permission you
know who else doesn't have permission my
kids
because they're seven and thirteen they
can't buy beer yet so they don't get a
vote
right like we walk around especially
social media we walk around and we let
everybody else tell us what we should
and shouldn't be doing and feeling who
we should be hating and what skills we
should have and what skills we shouldn't
have and that's too Mexican that's not
Mexican enough oh and by the way when
you learn Spanish you're not going to
learn the right accent you're not you're
gonna you're gonna be a white Spanish
speaker right I already am I know and
then you're gonna be a white Spanish
speaker like you can't win that game
right right and I spent a lot of my
career studying inside of racial and
ethnic diversity
there's colorism within that
you're too dark of a Mexican you're not
you're too light you start playing those
games and you don't win and what you're
doing is you're taking you're
Outsourcing you to everybody else and
saying do I have value do I have value
do I have value
yeah
and they don't get a freaking vote
because you're married from Bakersfield
and your parents
um your your bio lineage they let you
down and I'm so sorry
but from today forward as long as you
carry that that is you choosing I want
to wake up and have a more miserable day
I want to wake up and die a little bit
younger
because I couldn't set that down
how do I set it down you have to set it
down got to make a choice to set it down
I it can be as simple as this
once you go to to to Home Depot or
Lowe's
um and go buy a cinder block go purchase
one
purchase actually you probably need
three or four you've had a rough go
and I want you to take a um
cinder block and put duct tape on it and
I want you to write mi madre and I want
you to carry that sucker around with you
until your arms are so achy and it's so
heavy
and to you kink I can't hold this any
longer
and then I want you to take it out in
your backyard and I want you to throw it
in the furthest corner and tear the tape
off and look at that thing and say I'm
never picking this up again
and what you will have done it's a tiny
little Annoying ceremony
kind of like a funeral if you will
you when you have a funeral you always
know that your loved ones is where they
are where they're buried their their
pain your pain is still in your heart
but you exhale there's a period at the
end of that sentence
and then at some point I want you to
write a letter to your mom
and ask her all of those questions what
was so bad about me
mm-hmm
write that letter to your dad you're not
going to send it this is for you I want
you to write a letter to that 14 year
old Mexican girl in a white ohioan home
Ohio and home
who felt has felt out of place her whole
life just lost at sea
and let her know she's amazing
see what I'm saying
your body's been at War since day one
but I I I I my my prayer for you is
peace
I'm gonna I'm gonna send you a copy of
own your past change your future my book
okay I want you to read it start to
finish
and um it's just me my gift to you will
you read it if I send it to you yes yes
yes thank you okay
um
in about a month if you will practice
these things I want you to call me back
and I'll even have you back on the show
and listen if if I have you back and
you're like oh I did all these things
that you said and you're stupid I will
you can tell the world this guy's a
fraud he doesn't know he's talking about
but if you'll do those things and you'll
keep a journal of all of your negative
self-talk the shoulds I got to's I have
twos no I don't I'm freaking Mary from
Bakersfield I'm worth being loved and
this person who I don't know who just
stopped me and in line at a grocery
store and said something to me in
Spanish and I responded back espanol and
they made a face at me
I don't even know who they are
I'm not gonna let them ruin my day I
don't even
I'm going about my day this is Mary from
Bakersfield
my life is good
choose peace Mary thank you so much for
being brave and thank you for the call